Genghis Khan was an unusual conqueror
yes he subdued vast lands from atop a
horse but he didn't brag loudly across
the ages he kept secrets a secret
history a secret burial no images from
his life conquered people's weren't even
allowed to learn his language with all
this secrecy could we ever know what his
language sounded like my first encounter
with Mongolian imagine me working at a
coffee shop for years I spent my morning
steaming customized espresso elixirs for
customers to carry out with style but
after my shift I'd relax by heading
three blocks to the library and picking
grammars off the stacks this day I
noticed a new book I opened it and met a
language that built words mechanically
that had vowel harmony long vowels and
an L it warned me it would be tricky to
pronounce fun until one example broke my
flow something something something
Chinggis Khaan suddenly this wasn't just
grammar it felt like history Mongolian
the mongols was this the remnant voice
of the Great Khan himself I didn't
realize it at the time but this
curiosity would lead me down an epic
road books maps a pig Rafi late into the
night following nomadic hoof prints to
chase a language and if you want in on
that journey we traveled to Mongolia
today fly in to Lombok
the red hero city and you'll see one
name at the airport on bottles a hotel a
bank and the character atop the world's
largest man on horse statue southeast of
town not Genghis Khan but chingus ha yes
in Cyrillic no this isn't Russian it's
Mongolian just like in that grammar
endings with vowel harmony postpositions
not prepositions long vowels like Tong
and elves and ELLs of
cross the border into China and you're
in Inner Mongolia as you look around at
shops and signs it can be hard to
imagine that a roving shrine to Genghis
Khan once toured this region for the
devout after his death but focus above
the Chinese and you'll spot some
Mongolian in an older alphabet with
toothy consonant vowel letters connected
along a cursive spine it's unique in the
way it's written from top to bottom and
it rose from left to right for beginners
it's a challenging script I mean this
thing kind of breaks web pages but to
ease the pain children here learn it as
syllables when they recite words with
these syllables something strange
happens
extra unspoken syllables emerge the word
Heath hey lis caught the blue city of
Inner Mongolia is whole hey Kota and the
four syllables of lagron bottle are
written with six where do these extra
syllables come from from back in time
1204 before his Khan the up-and-coming
Tim Wu Ching conquers a tribe to the
south the nemah among his new subjects
is a scholar Pat Otunga who writes in
the Weaver script which his people
inherited ultimately from Aramaic
there's a whole backstory but if it
reminds you of rotated Arabic there is a
reason it's emerging maybe illiterate
but he immediately recognizes the use
for his dawning Empire and so trusted
Mongol Nobles learned to write later
that same century a great stone goes up
with an inscription telling us that a
skilled archery seunga shot a target
from 335 alts away more than half a
kilometer the first words in the text
reveal who was there to witness it
jingis Han and his Mongol dignitaries
this is pre classical written Mongol it
often resembles modern Mongolian a kid
is still a kid but it preserves sounds
that have since changed like Edel has
since harmony
to Alder those long vowels were actually
two vowels split bike kahan instead of
ha which by the way is why Khan also
gets spelled with 2 Oz and I her between
this official written language takes us
back to the right time but another line
of evidence suggests it might be
suspiciously archaic how dignitaries
wrote but not how the columns spoke a
crucial piece of the Mongolian story was
nearly forgotten a history book
disguised as a language instruction text
was rediscovered by russian orthodox
monk Pelagius in china in the mid-1800s
this book was written entirely in han
chinese characters but despite
appearances it doesn't make sense if
it's read in Chinese listen to the very
first words
jingis kahan we meet again what emerges
is a long name filled text telling the
inside story of the man himself his
origins from Tinga t his andhe his blood
brother his conquests with his general
struggle for succession even a cameo by
that same longshot Archer oh and time
and again you'll read how in Chinggis
Khaan made a decree he made a decree
saying dot dot dot it all structs
scholars and nomads alike as authentic
perhaps composed upon his very death
when Nobles gathered together to
remember his story their story and wrote
down what came to be known as New Echota
pian the secret history it's from the
right time but something felt off a
daughter had already changed to Odle
they were already dropping their middle
hoods and yet they kept around an
initial her
huija in all this secret history looked
different mostly younger maybe written
mongol was too old to be the language of
the cajon maybe this was his middle
mongol
so why not just roll back today's
pronunciation and undo sound changes to
revert to our best middle Mongol accent
is the question you ask yourself as we
travel the open road through the Ordos
in inner mongolia to this site of the
mausoleum of chingus hon or dosa became
our horde but it means palaces his tomb
remains a mystery yet after his death
tent palaces wandered this land as a
shrine to what one scholar terms genghis
it theology in tang grism a people
called the docket vowed to guard it
forever and their mongolian is different
they're not alone there are languages in
Russia that inherit over 90% of their
words from middle Mongol while one in
China keeps less than half as I promised
it's a lot of wandering but the point is
there's not one Mongolian it's a
Mongolia family even my grammar naively
titled Mongol in was teaching just one
variety hike linguists sifted through
mongolic cognates to piece together a
common ancestor proto mongolic had a
knot it had no F's the hog had a cut and
final m hadn't merged with n so they
were saying kahan cuz were dropping but
lingered at the start of words
mahjong was : sometimes evidence
conflicts was their garb a dippin or
dicking or it reveals quirks Mongols
used echo nouns for and things like that
muddy muddy for horses and more zzz's
and looked so much like middle Mongol
like another line of evidence pointing
back to the exact same time only 800
years ago it's a very young family
compared to others read mad it's hard to
reach beyond that so here he sits before
him we detect Turkic loans like his very
title maybe dialects or even a link to
this mysterious script after him
many mongolic descendants
and between a linguistic bottleneck
caused by a man who United a people and
drew a line in the Gobi sand from which
emerged a language family through old
texts and modern voices we still hear
echoes of when he made a decree he made
a decree but without saying the sound
fun
so at his linguistic legacy to the many
accomplishments of a man who to us is
genghis khan who in mongolia is
remembered as Chinggis Khaan but who in
his own tongue may have been
jingis kahan stick around and subscribe
for language
[Music]
you